à moins de trois semaines du premier
tour de la présidentielle ce sont les
artisans et commerçants qui s'inquiètent
de leur avenir
c'est le cas de ce patron de bar en
disant ils constatent bien la
dégradation que subit le secteur du
commerce
pour lui c'est le régime social des
indépendants qu'il faut absolument
revoir
nous on a démarré il ya quelques années
on avait 72 % de deux charges englober
donc avec des avec donc deux salariés
maintenant on est à plus de 75 % de
charges sociales
c'est énorme donc il nous reste on a un
frigo qui qui tombe en panne ou
n'importe quoi il faut qu'on aille voir
soit le banquet si on est juste il faut
avoir un petit pécule de deux côtés quoi
et de toute façon on peut pas s'en
sortir comme ça on est toujours obligé
de travailler avec les banques
si les politiques délaissent les
commerces les commerçants eux ne
délaisse pas la politique comme le dit
ce coiffeur la présidentielle on parle
que de ça avec les clients le commerce
compte aujourd'hui 3 5 millions de
salariés
il est l'un des premiers pourvoyeurs
d'emplois en france pourtant le patron
de ce salon est dans l'incapacité
d'embauché je suis le premier à vouloir
embaucher nous avons ces entreprises
donc on a pu prendre personne dans le
salon
les premiers à vouloir embaucher mais il
faudrait
des choses des contreparties si on
baisse les charges on embauche ça c'est
clair
après la coiffure direction les fruits
et légumes corinthia ce petit stand
charmant avec son mari elle est en
colère
pour elle ce sont les géants du commerce
qui portent préjudice aux petits
indépendants comme elle le dit on
produit du qualitatif que eux ne font
pas les bons produits
ça un coup de bâton pour avoir été pris
mais la qualité
le problème c'est qu'actuellement on a
face à nous des géants qui détruisent à
pas de géants notre planète et en même
temps et qui ne détruisent nous nous les
petits commerçants
dans la foulée il est politique laisse
s'installer ça pour les derniers
commerçants c'est terminé c'est une
autre partie
c'est un peu résigné mais on ne donne
pas la dynamique pour nos jeunes on ne
donne pas la dynamique pour au pied de
repreneurs derrière nous alors c'est
dommage
c'est dommage si entre 2011 et 2015 le
commerce a créé plus de 550 mills
entreprises près de 390 mille autres ont
dans le même temps disparu beaucoup de
commerçants ne voteront pas par manque
dans vie où vous tron pour l'extrême par
manque de propositions des autres
politiques
signe d'une présidentielle unique est
amer